Russia has rejoined an international
agreement guaranteeing safe passage for
Ukrainian grain exports the Kremlin says
it has resumed cooperation after
receiving written assurances that Keef
will not use the Black Sea Corridor for
military operations turkey announced the
deal and says African countries short of
food will get priority on grain
shipments
it was the Turkish president who broke
the news of Russia's U-turn the update
seemingly arriving in a note
then there's a long moment of silence
as he appears to digest the details
before announcing the deal is back on
Russia
now a piece of good news
following our talks with Mr Putin
Russia's defense minister called our
defense minister and said grain
shipments would continue in the same way
as before as of noon today
foreign
the announcement greeted by a Fanfare of
Celebration a sign perhaps of turkey's
role in the hard negotiations to get
things moving again
despite Moscow pulling out of the U.N
brokered agreement over the weekend
ships have continued to arrive in the
Black Sea from Ukraine these carriers
are full of grain they'll now be able to
deliver vital supplies to poorer
countries that's because Russia claims
Kiev has now guaranteed that it will not
use the routes for military operations
for President Putin has made clear this
pact remains paper thin
Russia retains the right to leave this
agreement in the event that these
guarantees from Ukraine are violated
foreign
stuff including corn wheat and soya
beans have already been shipped under
the Black Sea grain initiatives so far
and keeping the flow of supplies running
through this vital shipping route could
well help Stave off famine for Millions
around the world
we asked our correspondent Dorian Jones
in Istanbul how significant this deal is
for turkey and as president
absolutely on an economic level food
prices like in much of the world are
soaring in Turkey in fact nearly that
triple digit levels now that is a
massive problem further one facing
re-election next year but also
diplomatically it is very important too
it is made out one again a world player
he's prided himself in having good
relations with not only Vladimir Putin
but also with the Ukrainian president
zelenski that made him say in a
basically unique role and his role in
apparently getting the Russians back on
track again uh into this grain deal is a
testament to that and also this is
giving third one diplomatic cover he's
facing growing criticism over his stance
of refusing to enforce Western sanctions
against Moscow with concerns that
turkey's becoming a back door to
breaking those Western sanctions but
erdon's always insisted he can't enforce
those sanctions and and remain a
balanced player and a fix set apparently
in getting his grain deal back on track
is the Vindication of erdogan starts and
the grain deal is coming up for renewal
in November the 19th uh is expected to
play a very tough stance on getting that
deal to go forward and third one is
expected to play a pivotal role in
getting the deal renewed
Ukraine is meanwhile trying to restore
electricity and water supplies damaged
by Russian attacks on its critical
infrastructure Keys mayor says the power
and water in the capital are back on but
authorities are warning of rolling
blackouts to conserve energy with winter
approaching there are growing fears that
many areas could be without power heat
or water
and I can now speak to Kira rudig she's
the leader of holos which means Voice or
vote and opposition party that entered
Ukraine's Parliament for the first time
in 2019. thank you so much for joining
us today miss rudick
um I want to start by asking you about
Ukraine's critical infrastructure
because it has taken major hits in these
past weeks how do you plan to get people
through the winter under these
conditions
hello thank you so much for having me
well uh indeed 40 of the critical
infrastructure right now is destroyed or
damaged with a little chance to be
repaired very quickly especially that we
have encountered uh additional attacks
on the objects that we were able to
rebuild after the initial attacks three
weeks ago
if beforehand we were very sure that we
will be able to survive ottoman winter
and people were ready that it will be
hard right now uh we are all uncertain
and we are encouraging people to get
ready to rely on themselves last week in
Kiel was extremely hard for a couple of
days many uh people's experienced uh
absolute electricity outage and water
supply outage and I can tell you there
is a huge difference between sitting in
the bomb shelter with the heat on
electricity and lights on and we're
sitting there with the children in the
darkness without any heat and without
the the phones being charged and it's
just like a completely different feeling
and of course it affects people however
we haven't heard people complaining and
everybody is getting ready that
um that these attachment may continue
and that it will be another challenge
for all of us to go through autumn and
winter with uh with this uh closer to
humanitarian catastrophe you're telling
people to prepare to rely on themselves
what can Ukraine's allies in this
situation do to help what what do you
need most urgently
the main thing that we need same at the
on the day one of War we need air force
Protection Systems to protect our
existing infrastructure objects from the
further destruction this is critical
this is the best investment that our
allies can make
is to get us these systems in place so
then we will know like this is what we
have if we had this Air Force Protection
Systems in place a month ago right now
100 of Ukrainian infrastructure would be
intact and we would be very sure on how
we are going to go through the winter
second point of course right now we need
resources we need money to rebuild the
the energy infrastructures uh quickly
this takes uh a lot of of our
non-existing resources and a lot of the
support that we planned to spend on
refugees on rebuilding of the roads
right now then all all of those
resources are being spent on rebuilding
of critical infrastructure and this is
why there we need more and more support
of course our allies will uh also share
the burden of people who will be moving
to the European countries as the third
wave of refugees that we are expecting
uh to happen within the next months when
the cold hits uh it will be very hard
for people who will be unable to
um to support themselves and they would
probably uh go somewhere where they will
hope to find worms where they will hope
to find
the sustainability for themselves
especially people who need medical
assistance because right now it is
extremely dangerous because you cannot
rely on on hospitals because there will
be no electricity there Ukraine in
opposition politician Kira rudick thank
you for your time tonight
thank you and glory to Ukraine